reggie yates he's a critically acclaimed
filmmaker a writer a director and
an entrepreneur the first time i saw a
machine gun was
in my estate at like nine years old when
the police were raiding a flat on my
floor
because there was all kinds of craziness
there when you're just playing on the
balcony
as a teenager presenting kids tv with
air force ones and the mecca tracks
it says something i'm on the bbc and i'm
dressed like the boys that you cross the
street from
subsequently you know i've had kids come
up to me bro i loved watching you
because we dressed the same we talked
the same and you were doing that
and when people say things like that to
strangers it's so powerful
for me empowering others is a huge part
of my drive right now
working with young talented people and i
love that i have that relationship with
people because i never had it growing up
there was always a distance between me
and the person that was helping guide me
shortening that distance for me in the
lives of others
is what success feels like
[Music]
reggie yates he's a critically acclaimed
filmmaker a writer a director
and an entrepreneur and over the last
three decades
he's been on our screens and through
that time
the world has changed the platforms have
changed and he
has certainly changed he's been involved
in scandals
wild success and unfortunate failure
reggie's work as a filmmaker is
extraordinarily diverse
and he's traveled across the world
meeting those that have oppressed and
those that have been oppressed
and this conversation is the same
incredibly diverse we'll touch on
everything from love relationships
struggles
family mental health ambition council
culture and
everything in between thank you reggie
thank you for your honesty because i
know the people that are about to listen
to this podcast are going to take a
tremendous amount of important value
from it
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the dire of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
reggie um location
environment family where do you come
from
um i am the child of african immigrants
both my parents were born in ghana and
came to london as children
i was born on tottenham court road so
i'm london london london
and i was raised in holloway i moved to
south east london when i was 14 and
18 i moved out and i've been a londoner
ever since and i say that because
i've lived all over you know london's
quite a tribal city uh between football
and the club you support and the area
that you're from and
your connection to it i've lived all
over and i call south london home
now even though i didn't start there and
i didn't school there really
um but i love it there and it's nice to
return to the place that i spent a chunk
of my teens
so two parents from an african uh from
ghana
great ghana they came here when they
were my mother 11 i think my dad was
maybe 15 or 16.
so tell me all about that and that
experience because i know that in terms
of like education and perspective on the
world and all those things from my
own mom's experience she she couldn't
read or write right so we had
a ton of wars growing up because i
dropped out of university after one
lecture so we didn't speak for three
years
i know that african parents have a
certain perspective and i know
especially from reading about how you've
handled things like fame
press drugs alcohol and the avoidance of
all of those things
i know i feel like much of that must
have come from those kind of values
yeah um i'd say it's a combination of
things it's a combination
of the mentors that i chose uh the
environment that i was in at home
and that massively comes down to culture
you know
and that's why i was really interested
in your connection to nigeria because
culturally
for me um where my parents are from has
informed massively
in a lot of ways my outlook and
culturally obviously you know
when you've got west african parents who
were born there
you're raised in an environment where
education is everything because
as far as they're aware that is the only
way to unlock
uh another life for yourself my
grandparents came to this country in
search of a better life for not just
themselves but their children and
ultimately us their grandchildren
and it worked you know my mom got an
education
i got an education to a point and
weirdly my social education
and my extracurricular activities have
given me a career
so um more than anything i think it's
the values
of an african house that have given me
what i believe
to be a healthy life and i mean in every
sense of the word
people talk to me a lot about being
grounded and understanding what being
humble is
and i think when you've come from
nothing but at the same time
you enjoy everything it changes your
perspective on what success looks like
and that was the house that i was raised
in we celebrated
every day because we
essentially were striving to be happy
and happiness
didn't come from material goods it came
from
success and achievement uh on a level
that made everybody in the house proud
as opposed to what was going on outside
the family home
because culture was everything and do
you feel that do you still feel that
and did you ever fully believe that
happiness would come from success and
achievement do you still do you still
deeply believe that for me happiness uh
comes from being fulfilled i think um
in my at my most happiest and my most
calm
i feel like i'm able to love and i feel
loved
i feel as though i am professionally and
personally fulfilled
um i feel as though i'm creatively
fulfilled they're the moments when i
feel my most happy and they're the
things that i'm chasing if ever i was
chasing anything
and what was that what was the kind of
difference in between your mom and your
dad my mom was
nigerian yeah i didn't i don't really
have to say which my mom was nigerian
right my dad was the antithesis of that
my dad was a
what is a um older
white male very passive very very calm
usually doesn't speak
wow and my mom was she can shout for
seven hours at
a tone you've never heard in your life
without like taking a breath
amazing so was there a huge difference
between the
the sort of values or the approach of
your mum and your dad that had a sort of
a significant well my dad's a musician
was is and continues to be um but he
wasn't in my life
my parents divorced when i was quite
young and then my mother remarried
a another garnier man who was also from
a similar background
um and in terms of who they are
slash were as people it's very different
um
i think i get a lot of what makes me me
for my mum my mom was incredibly social
she loved music i've spoken about this
before she used to always cook with this
sony ghetto blaster above the cooker and
you know
it's west africa dean so you're using a
lot of palm oil so there was like
the the ghetto blast it's so like clear
in my mind it's just
covered with red oil and like there was
there was no cover on the tape bit so
you used to have to push a tape in
and there was like marks on it as to
where her favorite radio stations were
so
i was raised on a diet of pirate radio
and pop
um and that was my mum it's just a
vivacious big social animal like i
remember her 30th birthday because
you know she had us quite young and her
just with a [ __ ] out the window like
having a little dance or whatever and
like turning up her favorite records and
my stepfather is not that you know he's
not particularly social and he's quite
different and
his dad was in the military so he was i
imagine not that dissimilar to your
mother it sounds like
so um there were two very different
types of parenting in my house and as i
say my biological dad
wasn't present and ironically we're
probably really similar
given our you know our expression
through creativity
have you ever reconnected with him yeah
um yeah
so i did who do you think you are yeah
the bbc one show
yeah and it's really interesting because
they
they started carving up episodes of the
show and putting them on youtube
and they chunked my episode into four
parts
and uh on my father's side of the family
my biological father they've been
mixing for generations you know like
three of my grandmothers are mariah
carey black you know like they're
super super fair because there's been
generations of people that are
of mixed origin and with ghana um
previously being part of the british
empire
and being part of the commonwealth and
ghana finding independence in 1957
there was a huge uh english contingent
particularly
uh in around places like cape coast um
when it came to trading when it came to
gold etc
um and that's part of my family legacy
massively so you know my mum was
bitterly disappointed after they did the
research and realized that
her family background which was just one
village
versus my dad's side which was lots of
different people from different places
in europe coming to africa and mixing so
on and so forth so
when we made that show i realized that
they wanted to start
the show with a conversation between he
and i talking about the family
and i hadn't seen him or spoken to him
in over a decade so we met up just
before we recorded
and it was it was weird because i hadn't
seen him in so long and then when we did
record it's interesting like the film
starts with
the sequence with he and i sort of
chatting and he's playing thumb piano
but
the last time we saw each other with
each other was the day before
but prior to that i was a lot younger
so yeah i was a teenager the last time
i'd seen him so
is it i don't know i i don't really have
any bitterness towards the man because i
understand him a lot better now as i've
grown and as your friends become
fathers you sort of start to identify
just how many people are actually
naturally equipped with fatherhood
and not everyone is and unfortunately my
father just didn't seem to be one of
those guys
one of the things i i got to be honest i
worry about with
my own experience with my parents is
that there are
slightly toxic traits that they have and
i think this is the case with all humans
but
you know my parents are humans too yeah
um that i'm
i'm concerned i will
pass on like with through generational
cycles and i think
the less aware i am of those things the
more they stand a chance of like
showing up at some point and running the
show when it matters the most
yeah do you have those fears have you
ever had that you know they had those
fears i don't have them anymore
okay and the reason i don't have them
anymore is because i recognize that you
know
i define my my present and my future my
past i have no
control over but um who i am today and
who i will become
is down to me um and that also
uh is massively dependent on my
understanding
of my childhood trauma of the things
that um
if unchecked could define me so
i've always been desperate to define
myself
even when i didn't realize that i was
doing it so you know
uh growing up in a council estate up the
road from here in holloway
and having friends who have exactly the
same setup at home you know
before my mother met my stepfather we
were a single-parent household on
benefits
my mom did whatever she could to you
know feed the family and move us forward
that was the same for the other boys on
the estate so if i was hanging out with
corey or tyrone or whoever
their house felt like mine and i was
determined to not be defined by the
things that we were being taught to
normalize
you know and as a result i just
have decided that that's not the life
that i'm gonna have and my children
won't
god will and i have you are when you
look at your career
you are a tremendous outlier in terms of
the journey you've
you've you've taken and what you're
doing now that's very kind thing and
then you trace it back and go you came
from a councillor state not too far from
here for you to have
gone on that journey and achieved the
things you have
i always i always think there must have
been certain
factors in those early years that made
you
take a different course to those friends
that might still be on the estate now
yeah it might have been
you know we talked a little bit about
values there it might have been you know
i don't know something someone said to
you an experience you had or just the
conditioning
whatever it is but my question is do you
and do you know what those factors were
that made you
an outlier i mean you sound as though
you've done
a lot of work on yourself and in the
little bit that i know about you
i get to meet people and ask so i
learned so much from these kinds of
answers right
and i've made documentaries for over 10
years so it's the same thing you know
you learn so much from your environment
if you're willing to drink in the
information yeah and
i just in thinking about between therapy
and also being um present in moments
like this
you know yes there are cameras but i'm
having a conversation with you
and i'm learning from you and that
certainly was the case
in 10 years of making films you know for
the bbc um
so when it sort of comes to me looking
at
how i've become the person that i am and
how my journey has played out the way
that it has done it's an amalgamation of
different moments and instances but
fundamentally it comes down to
a desire even as a kid to understand
and be aware and it's progressed into
this idea of being present
and understanding the moment that you're
in and why you're there and
and taking as much from the moment as
possible so as a child
i would always ask questions and i was
far too
aware of my environment for my own good
so for instance i'll
i'll never sort of forget going to my
friend kieran's
oh no yeah it was kieran buckley's house
i went to kieran buckley's house
in barnsbury and um
my mom was very protected so she
wouldn't let me play at friends homes
i know you know how that goes and i went
to kieran's and i was in the garden and
he had
this massive massive beautiful islington
garden with several trees in it
and i asked him how come you've got a
park at the back of your house
um and his mother sort of overheard and
laughed a bit and it stayed with me
and he's like that's not parks my god
are you talking about come on freeing it
in you're in goal mate and you play this
game you don't think about it and then i
remember going back to my cancer state
and looking at the
the one tree that me and corey used to
climb and think
i don't have what he has why is that
and then you start to think about these
things and then start to understand
class and where you are and
even so far as the area you know i
started to really recognize the power of
my walk to school even as a kid
before i got to secondary school i was
like this is really weird like i live in
a borough
islington in north london that has
everything from
council states with immigrants and white
working class
right the way through to multi-million
pound houses and i lived on
a row called liverpool road which is
such a it's such an important road
that i haven't only i've only become
aware of how important that road is to
my journey
in recent years so i lived at the
holloway end of liverpool road and
liverpool is a long road that runs
through
islington and at the other end is angel
an angel gentrified years before
holloway did hallway is a very different
place now
and they had a waitrose they had a
sainsburys and you had these gorgeous
massive townhouses and
you know if you deviated off liverpool
road you'd be in barnsbury and there
were these beautiful little villagey
roads
and holloway was where the people that i
grew up around lived
and you had these estates you had every
kind of madness you could imagine
happening on my estate like i remember
my first
the first time i saw a machine gun was
in my estate at like nine years old when
the police were raiding a flat on my
floor
because there was all kinds of craziness
there when you're just playing on the
balcony
on your estate on on the floor that you
live on you got on police there
you know let alone the other times that
you see other weapons or you see other
things happen
um and those walks that i would go on
where i would be like wow the bit that i
live in versus the bit that i'm walking
through versus the bit that i'm going to
to go to school
i know what bit i want to live on so i
better start thinking
about how i'm going to get to that bit
of the road it's so fascinating you'd
say that and it took me in my head back
to
back to my own experiences being a kid
and this really vivid memory i have one
day of
looking up at the sky and seeing a plane
and then looking down at my street and
thinking i wonder if all of these fam
this is what they wanted from their life
and then the plane for me was the
juxtaposition between a family going on
holiday
i'd never been on like other than coming
from africa we'd never been on holiday
yeah
so i was thinking oh my god people are
going on holiday and then i look down at
my street and i look up again and i see
this plane
and a lot of people will have that but
it takes a different mind to then think
i want to be on the plane i want to be
at the other end of
liverpool street um but then also
i have some idea about how to get there
or maybe you didn't have some an idea
about how to get there but maybe just
the
i mean if you believe in that
manifestation just that i want to be
there so i'm going to make decisions
over the next 10 years
in that direction right well my
journey's super weird right
because from the age of eight i was a
working actor
so i was constantly reminded about my
difference
just by being present and by being aware
even as a child so
it didn't take much for me to realize
you're not like your friends reg because
you're currently
working while they're at school and
you've been allowed time off school to
work so straight away you're like okay
i'm a bit different
and this is a bit of a weird situation
to be in and then you look around and
there's a hundred people on set and
you're the only black person
both in front of all behind the camera
and you go okay wow
um i'm not like any of these people here
and the conversations that you hear
about what people did on the weekend or
where they're going that even or even
conversations about wine like little
things that people take for granted
culturally
anybody drinking wine in my house you
know what i mean
like shallow was a big deal you know um
going to sainsbury's was a big deal like
we used to walk to dalston with
backpacks to go and buy meat and tin
tomatoes and carry them back because we
never had a car what does that do to you
though when you're on set everyone else
is a different skin color and they're
talking about things that you're not
familiar with in terms of like let's be
honest like class
right absolutely what does that do to
you and does it put a chip on your
shoulder does it
make you i'm more ambitious does it make
you think [ __ ] i'm i'm out of place i'm
an imposter
yeah well it could have put a chip on my
shoulder and i'm incredibly thankful
that it didn't
what it did do was make me so hungry
to create an environment where i could
feel comfortable
and what that progressed into was
understanding that it's going to take me
a while to get to the point
that i'd like to be at therefore it
would be and become my responsibility
to create that for someone else to
create that for another eight-year-old
me or 15 year old me
and i feel incredibly proud that i'm
able to do that now because
i recognize the power of it and
regardless of
those moments of feeling out of place or
being sort of feeling as though you know
your class is being
is being waved in your face like i told
this story the other day to a friend of
mine who's
i'm a godfather to his child he's one of
my good good good friends
uh sam wilkinson he's a director who i
made a lot of my documentaries with
and um he's got my gorgeous little
god son in his hands little teddy and
we're chatting away and i was telling
him a story about
uh being at this primary school in
island where you've got kids from
estates and kids from
quite you know affluent homes all in the
same school and at lunch time you had
these kids with thundercats lunch boxes
and these incredible sandwiches and
kitkat minis all the things that i never
had in my house you know
you're sort of looking at tinfoil that
hasn't been used 50 times and you're
like oh my god they're throwing the
tinfoil in the bin what the hell
what the hell is going on without being
made to fold and put it back because you
could use it for dinner tomorrow
anyway so you're like taking all of that
in and
every lunch time i'll never forget um
pat god bless her
uh the head dinner lady this big lady
big lady
would walk out and she'd go free school
dinners
and all the kids that were on free
school dinners used to have to stand up
and go and get your food and it sort of
broke you a little bit as a kid because
your mates were just a bit like oh my
god
can you imagine and i told this story to
sam and he started crying
and sam started crying i think not
because
well i think he felt a little sad for
little mini me but he also
as a father imagined his son in that
position
and i'm sure we'll get on to family and
fatherhood and stuff but i
you know i realize how much fatherhood
has softened a lot of my friends and
also has made
me very sort of cognizant of my journey
and also
just how important my childhood was in
shaping who i've become
and when you were there when you were in
school when you were eight years old and
working and acting
what were your dreams for the future and
how big were they could could you
what was that internal monologue saying
that the end of
reggie's story would look like i don't
know what it looks like now
yeah and then i never had any sort of
desire to create it or paint it
i just knew that it was fun and i
enjoyed it and i didn't quite understand
why i was getting paid to do it really i
just didn't get it because it was like
you mean i get off school and i get to
play make believe with people that i've
seen on telly
and you're going to pay me for that
right i remember my mom opening a bank
account for me
because i did a job and
this money started coming in and you
know suddenly you've got tens of
thousands of pounds in your account
you're not even in secondary school yet
and it's like well hang on this is this
is crazy because mum's
desperately trying to save to put this
on the table or to make that happen
and i'm getting to do something that's
fun and it's paying me really well and i
get to do it with
stephen fry and hugh laurie like what
that there though
for me speaks to a really critically
important part of like
success which is at a very very young
age you got to see behind a curtain
and the curtain was in my view just from
hearing what you said i can do something
that i actually like
and people will pay me for it and
imagine most kids from that estate
all they'll ever get to see is you work
in the factory or whatever you have to
hate your work
and you get paid [ __ ] all for it yeah
that's what did they you know
well it's interesting you said it
because you've actually weirdly picked
up on a really interesting point because
um
something happened on set in a moment
of realization even as a child that
only came back into my head popped back
into made a few years ago and i
recognized how important it was and i
actually put it in my book
and that was um
work to me based on my grandparents and
my mother was something that you hated
um my grandmother worked the buses
she was a cleaner she did all sorts of
stuff she was a
a cook for london underground at one
point i was at london bus one of the two
my grandfather had two jobs at night he
was a security guard at some random
factory in king's cross
and during the day he was a mathematics
professor at a university
you know it's an incredibly educated man
but because he wanted to build a home in
ghana and he wanted to look after
everyone
he literally worked all the hours that
god would send so whenever anyone spoke
about
work they hated it and then
the first job that i ever got as an
actor when i was eight years old was it
was desmond
which for anyone that um has seen it
will know
like retrospectively how important that
show was for those that don't know what
it is
uh desmond's uh i believe is channel 4's
longest running sitcom
and it's not on tv anymore it hasn't
been on for years but desmond's
was about a black family in peckham who
owned a barber shop
and it was a comedy about black life and
just about life and because it was so
human even though it was massively
flavored by this
caribbean family people loved it and it
was massive and it ran for i think seven
seasons right
so the first audition i go for is
desmonds
and i remember going to humphrey
bartlett i think it was the name of the
production company in kentish town
and we went up to their production
office and my mum was excited
you know she was prepping me on her
little cards like to get my lines down
and everything and i got the job
and then i had this random moment that
when i think back it's crazy for me as a
kid to have made this realization i had
this realization and that was
i was um i was on set surrounded by
people that looked like
me and my family you know you had
shirley who was the matriarch of the
family who actually looked like my gran
you had norman who played desmond who
was like the super funny old guy my
granddad was this funny old guy that
used to make inappropriate jokes all the
time and
all the makeup artists were black and
they would give me little boiled sweets
and
everybody was just so fun to be around i
was just surrounded by this blackness
but in a professional setting and
everyone was at work
and they were having a great time
and something went off in my head and i
was like wait hang on a second
maybe what i've seen in my family and
their relationship with work
doesn't apply to everyone because these
people look like my family and they're
having a great time
so what would it be like if i did that
for me
and that's exactly it and i a lot of
people
don't realize that and that's why i
referred to it as you got to look behind
the curtain right and once you see it
you can't unsee it
once you make that connection that you
can love your work
and it can be in line with your passions
i mean right now the stuff you're doing
in your career is
seems to be perfectly in line with your
interests you know and i've heard about
you know one point you were doing work
in music and you're interviewing pop
stars and you're asking them
questions you didn't want to ask them
and you've it feels like you've really
got closer and closer and closer and
closer to
doing work that's intrinsically
fulfilling as the years have gone on a
lot of people don't realize that reggie
and they don't ever get to see behind
that curtain
yeah so what would you say to those
people who um
have the have the dreams but they've
always believed that work is a
nine-to-five thing it's a chore it's
something you do to fund
your passion yeah or your free time well
it's really difficult in this era
because there are so many experts uh
on social media or on youtube and who
are releasing books or whatever you know
there's a ton of people who haven't had
any life experience which is why
people like you i think are so important
and i'm not blowing smoke here
you know you're having incredibly
important conversations off the back
of living a life and doing something and
you're still so young
you have earned the right to say this is
what i think
and feel and i'm willing to share it and
you continue to learn on camera
making documentary is a huge part of me
learning on camera and learning with my
audience
and i'm sure that you can attest to this
there's something incredibly powerful
about saying i don't know but i want to
learn and when you do that and it's
documented and recorded people come
along with you you know
and in this moment there are so many
people that just see the end result that
want to be gary vee
or you know want to shout advice and be
be the tough love guy
and there is merit in that and i think
that
you know for a lot of young men
particularly you can look at some i'll
use garyvee as an example i think he's
fantastic in
some of the things that he does and the
way in which he delivers a message
because some people need to hear it
similarly on the other side um a book
like the secret for instance
you know if you don't have people
constantly reminding you of things
like some of the messages that are in
the secret
you might need to turn to a book that
has them all in one place you know
and i think it's incredibly difficult
for people to
to be honest with themselves about
what they're capable of without willing
to do the work
yeah and so many people want the end
result
but don't respect or understand the
value in the journey
and we live in a microwave era where
everything happens overnight and people
come up and come down from
social media stars to reality tv stars
or whatever and
it just it it breaks my heart that
nobody's willing to just look back a
little bit
and see that everything that they're
doing has happened before
and it all ends in one way um and
without
sort of rattling on about it or anything
i had a conversation recently where i
realized how fortunate i've been to have
been around for so long because
i've had a career for over 30 years now
and i've seen the cycle
play out over and over and over again so
like being
12 years old and interviewing the spice
girls and thinking oh my god this is the
most amazing exciting thing ever
and then seeing their peak because you
know i interview them for wannabe
then you see their peak and then you see
the movie and you see them on packets of
walkers crips
and then you see the fallout and then
you get to where you are today and you
see
how that has played out but that's sort
of like a a bigger arc but you could go
even smaller you know in the boy band
era
you name them i interviewed them from
the backstreet boys to five over here to
whoever i met them when they were new
and excited then i met them when they
were arrogant and horrible
and then you meet them when everything
isn't happening anymore and they've got
that album no one wants to buy
you see the cycle happen over and over
again today it's reality tv starts
only the cycle isn't three albums
if you're lucky it's three years if
you're lucky it's three years yeah yeah
yeah sometimes it's three months
they do love island twice a year now
yeah you don't get to a million
followers before there's a new sexy eu
on the show
you know and what does that take to
i guess to in some degrees to to
reinvent yourself through
as the world changes as platforms change
to stay
relevant to you know what does that take
i
have no desire to remain relevant i
don't
care i will just continue to follow my
passions
and i i recognized uh the power of
platform
when i was 18 when some
random kid's mum stopped me on the
street and said you're a role model for
my son and i hated there for it
and then i realized i have no choice in
the matter and
the minute i realized that regardless of
how i feel people are going to look at
me because i have a platform
i understood the power of that platform
and that started a thinking process that
made me
desperate to get out of entertainment
and get into documentary because i felt
as though
with that amount of eyeballs i should
have something to say
and that's why i think documentaries
have naturally led on to me becoming a
writer director and filmmaker
and using art to actually say something
and
everything that i do now speaks to my
purpose
quick one so many of you who are joining
the huel family and becoming a hooligan
as we call it
and starting your fuel journey ask me
what my favorite flavors are and i've
been
quite i guess contradictory in the
podcast historically because
as he will introduce new products i get
new
favorite flavors and so here in front of
me if you're watching this online on
youtube
you'll see my favorite three products
that i literally don't can't imagine
living without at the moment so you have
the berry flavor ready to drink which
was my original favorite i have that for
convenience
that then was replaced by the banana
flavor which is my
favorite and now and so that's for
convenience day today
my favorite flavor as it relates to my
gym fitness regime is the salted caramel
powder
super low in calories all of your
vitamins and minerals
and 20 grams of protein in 100 calories
which is
outstanding um so these are my favorite
three products if you're going to try
huel
and you've got the same palette as me
start here
that's my advice that journey you've
described over
you know 30 odd years and the the cycles
and the
staying you know being at a point now
where you can still do what you want on
a big platform
there must have been a ton of failure
through that journey and people don't
talk about that because that doesn't
make for good instagram posts
typically you know like the day you get
rejected from the audition or whatever
yeah
what are the some of the critical
moments in your journey where you
encountered failure or rejection
and you had that sort of mental
conversation with yourself to figure out
what the hell this means
and what we do next um i
uh have done a lot of therapy and i'm
really thankful for it i started in my
20s and now in my uh my late 30s
um i understand the importance of
getting to know your shadow and uh
my current therapist i've been with for
a while now is an incredible human being
who
has given me new tools for the tool belt
i'm using the language i love this
i'm using the language and um just some
of the things that he's given me
have really helped me to understand me
at my worst
and one of the big triggers for me is
when my
character is questioned and i've always
struggled with the idea of people
getting me
wrong or thinking that my intentions
aren't pure
and i had a situation um a few years ago
now where i said something publicly that
offended a lot of people
and my argument was no no but i didn't
mean that
i didn't mean that and what i came to
realize was
your intentions mean nothing if you hurt
people
and in sitting with the community that i
offended deeply which breaks my heart
because my first ever mentor anna cher
who gave me my career in
in television it's from that same
community as well
and i learned and have learned so much
about that community and that faith
um and i felt as though i let so many
people down
and in having those conversations and
understanding that bro it's not actually
about you
it's about knowing the power of your
platform
understanding that you have a
responsibility when you open your mouth
because
you've worked so long that people listen
to you now bro
and respecting the fact that regardless
of what your intention is
if you hurt people you have to behave
accordingly and that was a huge moment
of failure for me
that i have learned so much from and
that i am
uh i'm proud of the lessons that came
from it
and those lessons i think have set me up
in such a way that
i'm excited about my future because
regardless of everything i've done i
feel as though i'm only really getting
started now
and everything that has happened feels
like practice in a way
so i'm gonna ask these questions because
i i'm scared that at some point i'm on
dragon's den now
i i have a podcast where i speak my mind
and i'm gonna say some [ __ ] at some
point
i've said to my team before i'm like i
know at some point i'm going to say some
[ __ ] that
is going to get me in trouble something
that i didn't mean or something off the
cuff or whatever you want to say didn't
mean again to your point it doesn't
necessarily matter but
um if i meant it or not what my
intentions were but
can you talk to me and we're kind of
talking about like cancer culture here
we're talking about
you know um someone that has a platform
that's speaking their mind that's
is using words in various ways um
so you're talking you're you're
referencing there there were some
comments made people there was an uproar
within the jewish community what was
your mental
journey from the second you you said
those comments
to where you are now can you give me
like a little bit of the journey of like
you see the uproar yeah is the initial
feeling of like
you don't get me that's not what i meant
absolutely yeah and then there's is
there anger there is there this
and then there's no anger it's just
disappointment because you know better
it feels as though it's the biggest
thing that's happening anywhere in the
world to anyone
and it really isn't but the bottom line
is
that you have caused offense to people
that
you care about you have working
relationships with people and so on and
so forth and
there's a lot of vanity that kicks in
hence me saying what i said about you
know you feeling that
it's the biggest thing because suddenly
your entire world is made up of people
who are either disappointed
or uh let down or angry with you and
rightly so um and
you just have to sit in it you just have
to sit in it and make those difficult
phone calls
and also be willing to learn and
understand that you were wrong
and i think when you are at your core
a good person which i believe i am when
someone tells you you're not
oh it's really difficult to get your
head around
but leaning into that and like i said
getting to know your shadow
um understanding why that's such a
trigger understanding what that is
setting off for you in terms of
things that may have happened in the
past etc um
it's uh it's a process that you kind of
have to go through that gets really
really dark and difficult and then you
come out the other side saying okay
i'm i'm proud of that den like i'll
never forget actually and this isn't
this is a horrible clan name drop but um
uh daniel kahlua said to me that um
actually off the bat like he and i had a
conversation about this whole situation
and he said bro um there's a reason that
golf balls have dents in them
i was like what do you mean he said well
you know golf balls with dents go
further
and i was like yeah and kalu was so
right you know
um i learned so much in that situation
that it
weirdly strengthened my relationships
with a lot of people from that community
and also my knowledge is better and my
knowledge of self is better in terms of
how i manage myself in complicated
moments
this idea of the shadow getting to know
your shadow i find that so fascinating
it's good stuff in it yeah it's really
good i've had that expression before
um yeah well i wish i came up with it
but i'm gonna pretend i did
but it's just knowing it's knowing what
your triggers are
knowing yourself at your worst and being
comfortable with it you know i
i can proudly say that i can't
there's very little that could happen to
me now that
i don't have something in place to help
me
navigate it you know i i so i've been
having this conversation with one of my
best friends
and he's i'm going to say the context
because i think because you've had
you've been through the therapy maybe
you can offer some advice sure
he was saying to me the other day that
he is so easily triggered in the moment
by certain things he thinks it's because
he used to get bullied when he was
younger on the playground
but for example if someone was to say
that he was wrong or present evidence
which proved he was wrong
or his romantic partner who he's i'm
currently with
were to get in a little bit of a tif
with him it's kind of like this red mist
and he can't control it and then ten
minutes later i don't know why i don't
know why i do that yeah yeah
how did how did you find out what those
triggers were and you said you've got
something in place to deal with it
what is what is that because he was like
in the moment when i'm
sat with my girlfriend at dinner yeah
and the trigger goes
if i walk off that's storming off if i
go silent that's sulking
so what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
yeah um well it's gonna sound ridiculous
but
listening is really difficult when you
feel as though you're being challenged
and nine times out of ten any conflict
that i've ever had hasn't
actually been about me so to have
the resolve to shut the [ __ ] up
and listen sometimes allows you to get
through the things that are triggering
or annoying or make you angry or
frustrating
and get to the heart of what something
what's actually being said and why
and then when you get to that it just
becomes so much easier because most of
the time it's not actually about you
you know maybe something you've said or
done is triggering to the person that
you really care about you sat across the
table from you
and if you're willing to get beyond the
fact that they're saying something that
in the moment makes you angry
you can actually move forward together
in a way that just didn't exist before
the the thing that's jumping in and
that's it's
it's commanding your brain to try and
win or to go for victory or self-defense
though
yeah that you know that can come from
the playground that can come from a
comment your dad made you when you were
four or
whatever so especially if you're someone
who has come from nothing and has
succeeded yeah you know it's you against
the world for a huge chunk of that you
know
earlier stage it's very easy to need to
win
everything in life especially arguments
but most of the time winning an argument
actually ends up putting you backwards
because what you described there is i'm
from what i understood is
ego yes you have to build and i
genuinely believe this too especially
because i was a very young entrepreneur
in rooms with
you know people that were not the same
skincare as me and three times my age
when i was first pitching my
my ideas and at some point you have to
develop a sense of like
huge confidence and self-belief which
has to kind of
flirt with having a big ego because
i promise you like as you'll probably
know um i don't want to speak for you so
i'm saying probably there
people will try and [ __ ] with you
especially if you're they i mean of
course because everyone's trying to win
in their own little personal war
especially if you're an outlier yeah if
you are the t-1000
yeah people really want to figure out
how they can break you
yeah and some people get off on that
yeah um
and i'm sure you've experienced that i
certainly have but
i don't know uh in my experience
a lot of the time when i find those that
that conflict where i find people trying
to push buttons
it doesn't take much thought to
recognize where it's coming from
right and most of the time it's not
about you i mean books like
uh ego is the enemy or you know uh start
with why like they're really or
leaders leaders eat last yeah the simon
says um
that's a great one for ego um i i sort
of learned a lot from that about how to
lead and
also what true leadership can do
and that sort of unnatural thing
of not being submissive but allowing
someone
to find their answers with your guidance
as opposed to you telling them
is so powerful because it just makes the
bond so much stronger
you said i read that you wrote that you
had what part of your therapy sessions
was to really understand your
issue with father figures and the
sort of tricky relationship you had with
father figures yeah yeah
uh there was a disappointment that i
felt even as a a young age
in that i didn't have the perfect dad at
home
or at least a dad that i felt that i
deserved as a kid because i was a good
kid i was
i was working i was doing well at school
i was clinging to my sisters like
i i thought i was a good kid and i felt
that i deserved a different kind of
dad at home especially someone as
someone who was so obsessed with tv you
know
i'm looking at uncle phil going why
can't i have what will and carlton have
you know i want an uncle phil um
and in going to some of the houses of
kids that i was going to school with and
seeing how their dads fathered them it
made me
um disappointed that i didn't have that
at home but
i've spoken about this before and this
is a book that i've been working on
uh called bits of dad um and i was
incredibly fortunate
um to have bits of dad um
because of what my mother invested in me
so my mother
taught me from quite a young age to
recognize what a good man
looked like which helped me pick the
right friends and ultimately pick the
right mentors and people to follow
so i say bits of dad because
i would look up to and ask questions of
mark who worked at the play center
at the after school club at my school
and he would help me with
sort of dealing with some of the
dynamics in my friendships at school
and then i had billy mcqueen who i call
my tv dad a producer who i met when i
was 12 years old at disney
who would answer any professional
question that i needed help or guidance
with
and then there were these other men who
helped me with self-discipline or money
or even
football or even you know conversations
about women and relationships
and amalgamated they made the perfect
father but i had the bits
and the bits were enough for me
so when you're going to therapy was it a
question you're opposing to your
therapist about how you get a better
relationship with father figures or was
it
a um was it about authority was it about
bro we've had so many conversations
about dad i couldn't tell you what it
was specifically but
i think just knowing that
being a good man is such an important
thing for me and my future
and knowing that i didn't have quote
unquote good men at home
uh has always been something that i've
revisited and tried to unpack and
understand
and um it's something that's in the
front of my mind in a lot of ways as i
said you know that so many of my friends
are now becoming fathers seeing how they
parent
and also seeing the decisions that they
make and now becoming a godfather for
the first time you know i'm not dad
i'm not a jace you're saying so i could
yeah yeah yeah you know you you go
around you pick up you change nappy
sometimes i haven't changed teddy's
nephew just yet because he does massive
um but um knowing that when that kid
gets a little bit bigger
i can help sam this guy who's a mate of
mine who i love dearly
and maybe the bits that he can't do with
the bits that he doesn't want to do
and i offer a different perspective as
well i
i one of the really sort of fascinating
point i've just become a godfather again
congratulations time last week
so that's and i'm particularly close to
the dad one of my best friends worked
for me for seven odd years so i feel and
it's also
the child is um so my friend is the dad
is is is black and
the the mum is white so the the kid is
probably going to look a little bit
a little bit like me so i feel a greater
sense of responsibility it feels like my
first
my first real kid um there was something
you said
a quote where you talked about really
understanding how precious your time was
and the the actual quote is no one like
me has had this opportunity
so i'd be a fool not to make the most of
it i really want to understand that like
driving force within
within you that's that's um still
driving you today and i i've sat here
with so many
um successful people so many successful
uh black men
um i've analyzed myself and it tends to
be a bit of a cocktail sometimes your
story from the council estate
sheds some light on that yeah and you
know liverpool wrote that really shed
some light on it as well
um and the bit we talked about being
underestimated and
you know feeling sometimes like the
outlier in certain rooms yeah
um but that thing about time and that
sense of responsibility
you speak to is because you saw that
word and you're right that was
almost your feeling of responsibility
yeah
it's really complicated and
i think the idea of responsibility comes
from understanding that i was one of the
first people to
uh be given a platform either on prime
time or on children's tv and so on and
so forth and
because i've always been myself
[Music]
regardless of who i was at that time and
you know having been on tv for so many
years
that version of me has continued to
progress you know as a teenager
presenting kids tv with cane row and you
know
uh air force ones and the mecca tracks
your academic sweatsuit
knowing that i'm not just wearing this
to my dressing room i'm wearing this on
camera
says something it says something i'm on
the bbc
and i'm dressed like the boys that you
cross the street from that was like
i understood even at 18 that that was a
thing
that meant something and subsequently
you know i've had kids come up to me
over the years saying i grew up with you
on tv and
bro i loved watching you because we
dressed the same we talked the same
and you were doing that and it just made
me feel like i existed
and when people say things like that to
strangers it's so powerful
and i assume that that might be the case
even as a teenager
and i'm so glad that i was right because
that desire to be me whatever room i'm
in
has served me well and that's gone from
presenting
kids tv right the way through to writing
and directing now like
i've just completed my first feature
film pirates
uh which will be out this year and i'm a
producer i'm a writer and i'm a director
in this movie about three
men of color men 18 year olds right
and i employed the crew
i am sat there in interview rooms
interviewing heads of department
deciding who is going to ultimately set
the mood
for this thing that really matters to me
because as a writer director it starts
with the script
but as a director you're on set and
you've got 150 200 people working for
you
and if you don't lead in the right way
they'll decide
what this environment is going to be and
the big concern for me was i'm looking
at
three versions of me i've got a moroccan
kid a ghanaian kid and a west indian kid
who were 18 who were leading their first
movie
i remember being 18 desperately trying
to get auditions for movies and not
getting them
it was a very different landscape then
so i understand the responsibility that
i have today
to put on for those guys for redder for
elliott for jordan
it's my responsibility to put on for
them and create an environment for them
in a way that just wouldn't exist
if the man at the top of the tree didn't
intrinsically understand them
because nobody understood me coming up
that's where the responsibility comes
you know so this is a tough question to
answer because i would find it
tough to answer but i'll answer it as
well if you want me to but
what what what is the best and in your
own self-assessment
what is the best and worst part of your
leadership style
um i think the it's easy to say the best
isn't it
i'm great okay let's start with worst i
think the worst part of my leadership
style
is that i want everybody to have a good
time all the time
oh okay interesting i do please explain
desperately well
when you're responsible for the
environment when you pick the people
if it goes left or if you pick the wrong
person it's on you
and it's your fault and that feels [ __ ]
when you get it wrong
and it affects people that you care
about that feels terrible
so i desperately want everything to work
out
in an environment where i'm responsible
you know so i think that that's probably
one of the biggest failures
that i hopefully will be better at in
the next project you know
to be really transparent sometimes you
have to replace people midway through a
shoot
and it's knowing when is the right time
and also having the balls to say
you don't quite get what we're trying to
do so thank you for what you've done but
your
your services are no longer required you
know that's difficult
yeah especially if you empowered them to
begin with yeah and to take it away is
tough
um i think the thing that i'm good at
is people management i'm good with
people i'm good
on a one-to-one basis as well as with
the group um
and i think the thing that i'm best at
is understanding my actors because i
once was one
and knowing that you know they just want
to do a good job
and are individuals some might require
talking to before a take some might
require being left alone
some might require some coaching or some
confidence boosting some might require
being told to rein it in
you know i with pirates
i decided that i wanted to make sure
that my three central guys
were a little family before we even got
on set so
i contacted one of my mentors um richard
curtis write director who
uh wrote uh notting hill uh
love actually four wins in a funeral um
he and his wife emma
uh freud who are amazing amazing couple
uh i met through comic relief which is
also something that they do i mean
they're kind of amazing uh when i was 18
i met them through comic relief and
they've been in my life ever since
and when i started writing off the back
of spending new year's at
one of his places i said look could i
would it be possible to take one of your
homes by the sea so i can go and write
there and they're like absolutely and
they've given me
they've opened their doors to me for me
to go and write at their
one of their their homes and the desk
that i i wrote
a few drafts of pirates is the death
that richard wrote notting hill on
so i'm rubbing my desk come on give me
some of this good stuff come on
um and prior to shooting
i the guys allowed me to i asked them
and they were absolutely fine with the
fact they
actively encouraged me to bring the boys
to the house for the weekend
we spent the weekend by the sea cooking
together watching coming of age movies
talking about the movies uh very much
about
friendship and coming of age but it's
also set in 1999
with a whole uk garage backdrop so the
entire music in the movie
is ukg and the boys are desperately
trying to drive from north london to
south london and the peugeot 205 to get
into twice as nice
on new year's eve 1999. that's the movie
it takes place over one day right
so you know we got like spoonie on the
phone or we got like the heartless crew
on the phone and the boys were just sort
of learning about garage and
they were also forming these
relationships and when we got on set
everyone was like oh so you guys have
been friends for years right and i'm
like no we just you know
just hung out and in now we're at the
point where we started doing screenings
people have watched it and they're like
the chemistry between the boys is unreal
and i say
all of this to say that the thing i'm
most proud of
is that i recognize what is necessary to
get the best
out of my actors and as a result i'm
incredibly proud of what they've done
i'm just really excited for them because
i know that
they're about to have very exciting
careers one of my actors red-eyes a
moroccan kid
and he's amazing he turned 21 while we
were shooting well during our break we
got broken up for kovit we got stopped
mid-shoot and we went back thankfully
and finished the movie but
red is this young incredible uh kid from
uh from morocco
london moroccan descent and he said to
me like in the audition i was like
you're
so naturally funny why haven't i seen
you do more comedy
and he said mate i only ever get the
the the child of terrorist the young
about to be turned terrorist role i only
ever get
those parts he said i've never read for
comedy ever because i'm always reading
for the same thing
which is why when this came across my
desk i've done everything i can to be
good at it because i don't want to just
play a terrorist
i'm more than that and for him to be in
this film and to be
so funny it's just the most amazing
feeling ever
to give somebody that platform you've
created so many critically acclaimed
amazing documentaries right and they're
so diverse in their
subject matter thank you yeah no just
i was going through yeah yeah it's
really just like it's
so diverse but i i wanted i wanted to
know of all and this might be like
picking your favorite kid or something
but
of all the documentaries and all the
moments and those those those stories
that you've told
is there something where you think this
is why i started
man that's so tough because there's
something in every film yeah genuinely
yeah it might even be the lesson that
you know you made a crap a crap
documentary and you knew it going in but
you did it anyway
there's been so many amazing lessons so
i think the thing that comes to mind
most whenever i'm asked this question
is um the south african preacher i made
a documentary called the millionaire
preacher
um and there was this guy
called uh umboro who is still active as
a preacher i mean he recently i think he
got arrested
for selling pictures uh to his followers
uh that he took when he went up to
heaven
so he recently i think has been arrested
for that i'm not entirely sure what's
going on with him now but anyway at the
time when we went to make the
documentary
with him he had a congregation of about
10 000 people and he was a
multi-millionaire several rolls-royces
you name the car he had
it mansions the lot and his entire
congregation was made of poor black
people
and he fell out with me
because he didn't think i respected him
enough
because i came to the film as somebody
who isn't particularly religious but has
a religious background i grew up in a
pentecostal christian church
my stepfather was muslim i converted to
islam when i was a kid
and in my teens i decided that faith
really wasn't for me in that
context so i'm looking at this man
thinking you are
literally exchanging people's faith for
their
pay packet and i was disgusted by him
by everything that he represented before
i'd even spoken to him
before i'd even begun to unearth who he
was and what got him to that place
and it was an incredible learning
experience when he decided that he
didn't want to film with me anymore and
you know his armed guards
were sort of like you know had their
fingers on the trigger as
i was trying to force the point that he
should keep talking to me and he was
just not interested
i i came to realize that
it's not about me the reason i was there
was not to have a personal experience
the reason i was there was to make a
film that could potentially
shed light on an issue or teach
something to people across the uk that i
would never meet and ultimately the
world as the film went on
on netflix and i had a similar situation
when i made a film about
being young black and gay i have a
family member who i'm incredibly close
to who is a gay man
and um his coming out was this
incredible moment for me in terms of
realizing
how difficult his life had been up until
that point
because of what he worried about because
of what he thought
might happen um and i wanted to make a
film about that
and cut a long story short ultimately
the film for me didn't feel as though it
nailed it
and i was really really disappointed and
uh the production company that i worked
with at the time would always do
screenings of the film as the films as
they went out so we went to
the exec's house and we're in his house
and we're in the kitchen watching it and
the credits roll and as the credits are
rolling everyone's sort of high-fiving
each other going ah we killed it we're
trending on twitter this is brilliant
everybody loves the film
and i'm just like that isn't the film
that i had in my head that doesn't speak
to the
the specificity of the experience in the
way that i wanted it to
anyway point being i went into my dm
on all the social platforms i was on at
the time and every
single mailbox was filled with messages
from young men and women
saying we saw that you were making this
film
so we purposely watched it with our
parents and i've just come out to my mum
because of the film you made i was able
to have a conversation with my dad
because of some of the things that were
happening on screen thank you for giving
us that opportunity thank you for
opening the door
and i felt like an absolute idiot in
that moment
because i was so busy worrying about
being missed our
program maker and making this film that
was perfect in my mind's eye
whereas in reality the conversation that
was being had had never been had before
let alone on the bbc and as a result it
actively changed lives
of people watching it literally changed
the lives of people that messaged me
wasn't about me and i felt really
embarrassed myself
it's really interesting that balance of
it being
not about you but it comes to me
yeah do you know what i mean it's that
it's that yeah it was it came it was
birthed out of your own personal
experience and your desire to tell a
very important story which had clearly
moved you emotionally
enough to commit your life a portion of
your life to telling that story so it
but but also i completely understand
what you're saying which is like the
outcome is not about you
i guess yeah um the experience is yours
yeah but the experience that people take
from the content you will never own
i will never know how much what i do
affects people or doesn't
there's someone out there right now
who's seen everything i've never done
and i'll never meet them
similarly there's someone who i'll bump
into tomorrow who's just seen one film
and will have a really important
conversation with me
you know on a lot of levels for both of
us potentially i'm not responsible for
what happens with what is created once
it's out in the world
and being comfortable with that is quite
difficult
but also quite freeing in a lot of ways
quick one as you might know i've
recently teamed up with a new partner
for the podcast
called my energy and they're best known
for their pioneering renewable energy
products
but they're also doing so much to try
and help all of us navigate some of
these
alienating um complicated terms as it
relates to sustainable energy
whether that's the term les or ules or
clean
air zones cars you can and can't drive
in london it can be a lot to understand
but these guys
are making it simple they have tons of
helpful guides explanations
q and a's and videos on their website
that make all of this stuff make sense
to
neanderthal idiots like me and they sell
some of the most amazing renewable
energy products whether you're buying an
electric car
or you're trying to find sustainable
ways to run your home
check it out myenergy.com they're an
awesome company round by an
awesome awesome founder one of the real
uk british success stories
and uh i couldn't be more excited to be
a partner with them and let's talk about
money then
so you mentioned money there what role
does does money play in all of this
stuff and success in your view in
in life well i've never chased it which
is probably why my account hates my guts
you know i walked away from prime time
tv that you know
is a very rare air in terms of the
amount of people that get to host those
shows that get millions and millions of
viewers and also the payment that comes
with it
you know i didn't enjoy
hosting those shows i didn't enjoy being
in that space i didn't enjoy being told
what to do
and say i essentially was being asked to
not be me
and that didn't work for me and in
walking away from that and focusing on
documentaries
i walked away from a lot of money and
knowing that i was going to take a hit
financially
ultimately being able to get to the
place that i am now as a filmmaker
um was something i was very aware of so
money has never been a driver for me but
it's been something that i've been
conscious on because you've got to live
right
and also i look after a lot of people
and i help a lot of people and i support
people
so i've always wanted to do that so
money has always been important in that
sense but it's never been important
because
i'm going to show you that jump you
described there where you swing from
being
like a tv host to saying you know i want
to make my own documentaries
feels like a risk it is yeah massively
talk to me talk to me about that the
feeling
you had when you thought you know what i
want to go and pursue myself now yeah
and my sort of intrinsic i always get
roasted for using my insurance i can
extrinsical
intrinsic fulfilling passion yeah um
despite that i'm gonna have to take a
financial
cut potentially yeah i might not you
know and the risk there's no guarantee
here right this might not work out might
not get commissioned
well it's the same thing with radio you
know i hosted radio for 10 years i was
at radio one for a decade
and i walked away i left hosting the
chart show
not because i was fired but because i
decided it wasn't right for me anymore
because i stopped learning
and for me it's always been about what
are you learning how much you're
enjoying this
and does this align with where you are
as a human being does this align with
your passions
does it align with what you care about
and you know i
you touched on yourself earlier in the
conversation when i
recognized that i didn't want to talk to
harry styles for 30 seconds
about the new video i wanted to ask
how the hell are you managing all of
this you're nine years old
like mate how are you managing this
there are grown
women that are hunting you down yeah
sexually yeah
and you're figuring out who the hell you
are as a person how are you managing bro
i wasn't allowed to have that
conversation on radio one
but i was in my documentaries you know
and
you know every form has its limitations
which is why
documentaries have um grown into
filmmaking
because now i can actively write
the conversation as opposed to sitting
down with someone
hoping that they're going to give me the
sound bite that makes that you know
makes that uh exciting for the audience
now i can write it
and through some of my experiences in
factual and life i'm able to create
people and create characters that are
flawed and interesting enough that
trigger conversations in the way that
i would hope to do in the approach to
making a documentary
whereas with the film drama specifically
i'm able to
literally lay it out and create it on my
own terms
and in terms of yeah and so in terms of
like fulfillment happiness mental
well-being
yeah how important is it to be your true
self you know and
you know again we talked about the lgbtq
community and how the struggles they
face
when the suicide rates are higher
because they they
are forced in many instances to live a
life that isn't true to who they
actually are
from your own experience i mean from
mine i know that i mean
when you're i mean you're doing it now
you're making extraordinary
work because it's connected to who
reggie is
um you i'm guessing you're you're more
happy you're happy
right you're fulfilled and um and it's
all
seems to be a really positively
reinforcing cycle when you get closer to
that
yes sense of who you are it's it you
know it is it's it's looking at your
door and i'm sure you have a similar
thing
you know you look at your calendar for
the day and you go what am i actually
doing today
and we've all had those days where you
see something in the calendar that you
don't want to do
seldom do i have those days now it's
very rare that i have something that i
don't want to do
um but professionally particularly yeah
um and i'm really excited by that and
i'm proud of that
you know um everything that i i'm
invested in
professionally uh comes from a place of
passion
so for instance i made uh you know
talking about social media and all the
rest of it i made a drama for the bbc
called uh make me famous which was a
standalone one-hour drama
about the relationship between uh fame
social media and suicide and you know i
created a character who was a reality tv
star who
after being on a hit show suddenly his
star begins to fade
and there is a newer younger sexier
version of him who's getting all the
accolades and love and suddenly his
rates going through the floor and
what that does to him on a on a mental
health level
and the conversations and research that
i was like embedded within in the build
up to write in the screenplay
were incredibly eye-opening for me
because i was talking to stars from
reality tv past and present
and hearing the difference between
people who have been on reality tv 15
years ago and today
was heartbreaking you know and seeing
the way that these kids
understand fame and and what they're
searching for you know
and also recognizing that i'm someone
who's hosted reality tv
you know and i have a really strange and
unique relationship with it so
my point is regardless of what it is i'm
doing
i care about it i care about it and
that's
anything from content to product i have
a dairy free ice cream
you know i have it sounds ridiculous but
i have a dairy free ice cream i'm a
creative director and business partner
and blue skies
but this is a dairy-free ice cream that
is made in ghana
it employs 3000 plus people the people
that work there
all look like me and my family and they
are being given an opportunity
to not only have a career but be paid
properly
and it's on amazon fresh and it's in
waitrose and people here are enjoying it
in the summer not thinking about it but
what it's actually doing
is incredible it's changed the community
and this is something that i'm connected
to so
whatever it is i do now if it doesn't
align with my purpose i don't want to be
involved
isn't it such a massive uh i reflect on
this a lot and especially when i'm
speaking to one that has
sort of immigrant parents that you know
our parents
central concern was survival yes and
what a privilege it is that people like
me and you can sit here and talk about
meaning and fulfillment and pursuing a
dairy-free ice cream from guys just
it seems like you know i think immigrant
children
will and hopefully understand the weight
of
that that response almost responsibility
you know when you when so close in your
your your family tree there was people
literally fighting for survival
yeah um i just think that's it but the
difficult thing about that is and this
is a conversation i'm having a lot you
know
talk about people becoming fathers a lot
of my friends are from a similar
background
you know black white and different you
know whatever children of immigrants or
white working class
now that they have worked hard and found
a level of success
and are now becoming the parents the
lives that their children have
will be worlds apart from the struggle
that they experienced
how do you navigate that relationship
with your kid
who for intents and purposes is
silverspoon because you've worked so
hard
yeah you've now made it easier for your
child and are you going to be mad at
that kid
yeah because things are easier how do
you raise that child with the same
values
you know i hope that's a rhetorical
question well i definitely don't have
the answer because i'm single i'm not
even a dad
so i don't have to have that
conversation just yet nice segue
to me
okay so you're single talk to me about
that how
are you going to be waving a partner oh
yeah this is like tinder cast
um amazing so so tell me is reggie yates
hard to date
uh absolutely why uh for the same reason
that you are
your business it's the truth it's the
truth i i i have a feeling everything
i'm about to say you will identify with
and that is the um
disclaimer everything i'm about to say
will probably make me sound like a
massive pratt so
please don't judge um
you're not like a lot of people uh
you're not like most of your friends
because of the life that you've chosen
for yourself and more importantly the
person that you've had to be
to become the person that you are which
as a result means that your dating pool
is small because
if we're talking about someone beyond uh
being attractive
and needing to have the value system or
the outlook
or and this is the really difficult
thing the understanding that you require
it suddenly becomes incredibly hard and
one of the stumbling blocks i've found
is hoping that someone will become the
person
that i really feel that i need in terms
of their understanding of me
um or expecting them to
and in doing the work and realizing the
role that i play in that i've been at
different times
very responsible in that
those moments of conflict should we say
whereas today
i'm just very clear about uh who i am
and also what i need and i think if
you're very
open and honest about that in the
beginning
it makes it easier but it doesn't make
it easy
and the pool continues to shrink the
more my world changes
because a a guy that was like a mentor
for me always described me as a moving
target like reg we're moving targets bro
like it's never going to be easy because
you continue to learn
you continue to work on yourself and you
continue to have that hunger to be
better
for yourself and for others and it's
incredibly difficult to find
someone that is either on the same path
or has the empathy and understanding for
you and the path that you're on
and the knock-on effects that that will
have romantically
so you said two things there that i
really wanted to jump back to before we
proceed um
with this topic you said you've come to
learn who you are and what you need
yeah who are you and what do you need um
i'm a fiercely creative person
with a very young spirit
who needs friendship and
understanding and empathy
as a writer you know when you're
building characters uh one of my
favorite things to do for my characters
is write down
what is the lie your character believes
and i think for the longest time i
believed that i would find a female me
and i couldn't imagine anything worse
today
and also you know you have to understand
the difference between your character's
wants and needs
which is why i find writing so cathartic
because i'm essentially doing
therapy on me as i'm creating different
versions of me at different points in my
life
and it's never going to be easy to be in
a relationship with someone like myself
or i imagine you
because we are moving targets i'm a walk
in the park
um going back to what is it are you
single
yeah how's that walk going for you
that's good okay so going back to what i
need
what does what does and i find this so
fascinating because you've described it
there like i've been on this journey
over the last 10 years where what i
thought i needed if you'd asked me 10
years ago i would have gone
this hair color these eyes this way size
this fashion sense and as i've got older
and older it's just come down to these
like fundamental
i guess principles or values yeah and
now there's basically only three of them
but i want to i really want to know
where you are with what you think you
need now
i think it's very simple uh it's to be
with someone
that i can love unconditionally and that
will love me
back unconditionally that's the simplest
version of it
and that is flaws and all and i think
it's also
the desire to be understood and
also the ability to understand because i
feel like
reg i feel like there's a lot of women
out there that would love you
unconditionally
and i still feel like that might not be
enough um
that's an interesting point i don't know
i think because i've had exes that loved
me i genuinely know
i'm thinking of one in particular loved
me unconditionally
but it wasn't enough okay so the point i
was about to make and i think that this
is something that might
i don't know i'm interested to see if
this speaks to you is
the understanding part of it right i say
understanding and it feels like quite a
blanket term
but what i mean by that is
culture is such a huge thing for me you
know
like i'm walking around at the moment
with this tiny little chain on but the
pendants on it
are jinyami which is a ghanaian
symbol which means trusting god i've got
a little
africa symbol and i've also got my
family crest right i don't even think
about these things anymore but
when i think about what i have on me
literally
my family is incredibly important to me
my relationship with my spirit is
incredibly important to me and where i'm
from
are incredibly important to me and there
is a huge difference between empathy and
understanding
and being in a relationship with someone
that doesn't understand those three
pendants
and doesn't well if they don't
understand those three pendants they
won't understand me
so when i say understanding i speak to
that
and it's very easy to say that you can
love someone unconditionally
but when you're someone like you or i
who meets a thousand people a week
some on the street some in situations
like this some through crew that you
will never meet again
you long to come home look at your
partner
and not need to say anything and for
them to understand you and that's why
understanding such a huge part of it
professionally as well right because you
because you coming your work's going to
take you all over the world and
you know an insecure partner might think
oh they might
try and compete with your work they
might be jealous of your work they might
well does that mean he doesn't love me
he's spending x time away in a jail cell
yeah
what about me it's part of it
yeah because work is and isn't
um it's a part of who i am you know i go
to the cinema twice a week
i've just put a movie theater in my home
and god forbid
anybody tell me that i shouldn't be in
there as much as i intend to be
movies have got me where i am and have
helped like i learned to shave
watching danny glover teach his son how
to shave and leave a weapon
films are a huge part of my life
and you can understand that you know
uh you have to understand me
professionally just as much as you do
emotionally spiritually
and culturally do you think in
relationships you're selfish
i definitely was not so much now um
i i i learned the hard way i've been in
failed relationships and i've also
even in my most recent relationship my
desire to understand
uh only went so far and i've you know
done some more work on myself
and ultimately didn't work out but i
think i understand why and i definitely
understand the role that i played in
that
last question on this particular one
before you can just throw it back at me
if you wanted because i've just been
like
refusing to give my perspective here
because i really i i've really
gained a lot from this kind of
conversation yeah sure um if you spoke
to your
former partners what would be the one
common
theme as to why they think the
relationship didn't work
um i think my my previous partners will
say that i
always operate with the best intentions
but didn't listen enough
and listening so important
oh my god especially if you've got a lot
to say and especially if you you've done
work and you know stuff
you think you know stuff um you can and
i certainly did in my 20s fall into this
belief that i knew enough and i didn't
need to listen to you because you don't
know as much as me i mean it's
incredibly unhealthy and potentially
quite toxic um
so yeah i think my biggest failure
romantically has been to not listen
interesting where are you i think i
think i i've been very uncompromising
and i'd say selfish
i think i'm definitely probably in
relationships other than my
ex who i've who's taught me a ton of
really important lessons about
myself and about patience and about yeah
just
really realizing that really because i
used to once upon a time when i was
younger i used to think it was all about
findings i've said this in the last
podcast but
finding someone that was perfect so
again i was i was in search of like the
female equivalent of me that was like
super career orientated had the same
beliefs as me
i saw the world would give me but it was
such a contradiction because i wanted
them at my beck and call
but then also wanted them to be busy and
when you analyze what i was
looking for it of course it didn't exist
yeah so the question in my mind moved
from being
are they perfect are they worth it and
when it becomes are they worth it
it's an immediate appreciation for their
and your lack of imperfection and also
that there's going to be some really
tough difficult times where
it doesn't make sense to you they're
worrying about something irrational
they're upset about something that
would never have upset you but you have
to as you said earlier you have to
listen and you don't have to agree
and in fact you don't have to tell them
that you disagree yeah you just have to
listen and hear them out
and that's a skill that i've honed more
recently in my
my last current relationship where even
if i don't
agree on everything i listen and
i will hear them out and yeah i'm
learning the lesson
how much do you take who you are
professionally into your romantics this
is a chip it's a perfect question to
follow up with
um no no surprise that you do what you
do because that's literally
what i what i've what i always ask
people which is in work context
i've been taught or in order to succeed
i've had to be someone
a set of values a way of speaking a lack
of compromise
a clarity of vision and it's worked out
and it works out
so i come home at night and i'm like
same clarity of vision
same like that no [ __ ] there are
emotions
yeah and somebody else's feelings yeah i
want if she wants to go to the park and
do a walk i'm trying to
from my business perspective trying to
understand what the roi on that is like
i'm like but that's not what i'm wearing
yeah like what the hell are we doing
having a picnic
like i've got money you know so i've got
money to make or something but i've i've
had to realize that i have to be
two steves to succeed or different
steves to be
succeed in different parts of my life in
certain contexts in a boardroom
if i'm doing a deal with a one of the
ceos of the biggest brands in the world
who is smashing his pen on the desk
telling me i'm an idiot and i'm at war
with him we're friends but this is how
these some of these people do business
i have to be a certain person right the
person i have to be when my partner
tells me something
like do you know about their personal
spiritual beliefs that i might not
understand in the full context
is completely different it's not about
being right or winning in that context
it's about listening
trying seeking to understand and trying
if i can to try and find the sort of
mutual bridge in which we
we both share values even if the words
we're using are different
yeah and i've been on that journey for
the last i'd say two years because of
this person i met who
yeah who taught me those lessons it's
empathy and understanding isn't it
ultimately that's what it comes down to
what about you on that on that question
you asked me there about the person you
are in work yeah and then the person you
are at
well work has to be quite black and
white in a lot of ways doesn't it you
have to be very clear and clinical
uh about what needs to get done to
achieve the thing
and that's just not the case when you're
dealing with a human being
if the thing is uh having a nice dinner
and having a conversation where
everybody feels heard
you can't be black and white about that
there is a gray area that
relationships romantic platonic
professional whatever that they they can
operate in that
require wriggle room and i think that at
my worst
i've not allowed for wriggle room when
it comes to somebody's outlook or
perspective
ultimately i am very happy that i am
where i am and i think i've
ultimately made the right decisions in
terms of my relationship choices and
whoever i end up with hopefully will be
the best version of themselves and i
will be the best version of myself and
we'll figure it out
but what seems to keep coming up for me
is
what the foundations of any healthy
relationship actually are
and the foundation for me that i'm in
search of is friendship
i think if i want to
not only spend time with you in the way
that i would a friend but also
i'm kind to you in the way that i am to
my friends
in terms of allowances and allowing for
uh being wrong and also figuring it out
and also having
a healthy conversation about something
when you're on different sides of the
argument
bringing that into my romantic
relationships has
already started conversations in a way
that feel healthier than anything i've
ever experienced before
how how did your parents how do you
think your parents relationship has
impacted
your ability to form relationships
massively
yes massively um again you know we're
talking about the journey of others so
i'll try and be as respectful as i can
but as an adult
who is now a lot older than my parents
were when they had me
um i'm able to have a little clarity on
their decision-making
and understanding that their age
probably played a big part in some of
the decisions that they made i'm sure
it's the same for you you know you look
at friends who
get married in their early 20s or um
essentially find their life partner
before they've had a life
and you can have an opinion on it but
you're not necessarily going to be right
because there's no way of knowing you
can have an assumption as to where it's
going to go and how it's going to play
out because let's face it
who you are at 21 is infinitely
different to who you are at 29 let alone
30 plus
[Music]
i just try my hardest to be as kind as i
can to the decisions that my parents
made
and how that in turn affected me because
i think culturally now we live in an era
where we think
more about our
how our behavior affects others than
ever before
and you know the way in which my
stepfather spoke to me at one point or
the way in which they interacted in
front of us as kids shouting
whatever it was you know um i don't
think it ever occurred to them
the effect that that might have yeah
that's not because they're bad people
that's because culturally that wasn't
even in the conversation
at that time so i hold no judgment
towards
uh parents from that generation um
i've got no excuse though because you
know when i'm a parent
i know better i've had 10 years plus of
therapy and also i exist in the
self-help generation where
we've read every book and we have
conversations like this and i have
conversations like this
with my friends and i know for a fact
that my dad
and my stepfather wouldn't sit around
with their group of
predominantly black friends and have
conversations about
you know healthy relationships and
mental health etc so
this is the last time i mentioned them
because i feel like i've said so much
about them but again richard and emma
when i went to their house um for the
first time in in notting hill
and i walked in and saw this sign on the
wall
it broke my heart and excited me in a
way that i've never been excited before
and those two conflicting emotions stick
with
such a visceral moment that i had that
no one in the room was aware of
they've got a bunch of kids they have
this lovely house where all their kids
at the time lived at home
and there was this neon sign on the wall
that said everything is going to be
okay with literally in lights on the
wall in their house where their children
were growing up
and it grounded me to the spot when i
saw it because i thought
subconsciously what is that doing to
these children
that they are safe as a message
in lights is something that they walk
past every day
to me that's what love looks like it's
being able to tell someone you love them
without having to say anything
based on the environment you've created
based on
who you are for them and them feeling
safe
that to me was in one moment
a real a real sort of
opener in terms of what i would be
searching for and should be searching
for
that feeling of safety from someone that
doesn't need to be said
is that is that in part because you
didn't feel like you fully had that when
you were
definitely i think it's partially
because of what i grew up in
and partially because of the
relationships that experience up until
that point
you know it's funny because you you know
a lot of things can we can sometimes
play play defense
play defense but it turns out well we
think we're playing defense but it turns
out to be self-harm
so we reject the chance of safety
because we're not comfortable with it
it's kind of like what i was
describing when i was 14 and jasmine
told me she loved me
i was playing self-defense but it was in
fact self-harm
you're trying to protect yourself yeah
in doing what feels right in the moment
but ultimately
you're killing something that could have
been incredible i think we've all been
there
i certainly have definitely i'm just
really thankful that i don't do it
anymore
i remember sort of rejecting this idea
of um of who my family was and how much
of an impact that had on me
and then when i embraced it and i
embraced the good and the bad i was able
to see so much of the good
you know my father who i don't have a
relationship with is an incredible
musician he's still part of a band to
this day
and you know i put on his album and i
cry
because it's like this man brings so
much beauty and joy to strangers
he wasn't able to give it to me but i'm
objectively able to find that beauty and
the art that he creates today
you cry when you listen to your
biological fathers particularly one song
jesus christ which song
it's called jojo's song and so we have
the same name i'm um he's called reggie
yes i'm reginald yates
and um he's obviously guardians because
you're
based on the day that he's born i'm not
i'm tuesday and so everyone calls him
jojo right so it's jojo's song and it's
a song where he's singing and playing a
fun piano and it's just oh my god
it's beautiful and to know that this man
who for
chunks of my teens i really resented
because i felt that he wasn't there for
me
has this beauty in him moves me to tears
whenever i listen to him sing and have
you forgiven him
i forgave him a long time ago because
i think it was like i said the point
when some of my friends started to
become fathers
you realize that not everybody is going
to get it right and not everybody's cut
out for it
and i was just unfortunate to not have
one of those world's greatest dead guys
i ended up getting a dad that just
really wasn't ready to to do it or grow
up
um and i can't be mad at him for
his journey that brought him to being
the man that he was when he became a
father
and on that point just to conclude that
point of the relationships love point do
you think you're ready
to be in that relationship that you said
you think you need
yeah i think so i think because
i'm on my journey professionally and the
worry of not getting there which could
affect you romantically doesn't exist
anymore for me
that's a huge thing that is taken out of
the equation of who i am romantically
i think because of the age that i am and
the experiences that i've had
i'm very close to being who i will be
for the foreseeable
yes i am a moving target but the
target's moving out you know
the things that are changing in me
aren't as big as they were in my teens
into my 20s
so meeting someone today and being with
them in five years i don't envy
just being totally different people it's
so interesting
it's easier yeah sure i love that point
and you talk about the moving target the
way that i've come to learn
to to sort of mentally understand it in
my mind is like
you imagine two lines and then from this
point onwards the lines start moving
and if they are one percent if say
the reggie yates line is just one
percent to the right
you and the other line will move apart
over time and i think i love what you
said there about like
i think i'll be a similar person in five
years time
which means like the degree of
separation won't be it's less yeah
so i think yeah that's a well the
greater journey has
been made up into this point and i mean
that personally in terms of
my development in knowing who i am the
level of self-confidence i have and also
what i'm fighting for
has suddenly been crystallized because
as someone who has
the ability to do lots of different
things i was running around trying to
figure out who i was supposed to be
and at the same time worrying about what
i was leaving behind for so many years
whereas now
i've tried loads of different things
i've had lots of different kinds of
relationships i've traveled i've done
all these different things
that i know what i want for me and i
also
i feel fairly confident i wouldn't say i
know but i feel fairly confident about
what love looks like for me
what success looks like for me and what
fulfillment feels like for me
which instantly makes picking a partner
all being chosen
a lot easier in that stage where you're
running around trying to figure out who
who you are yeah um for me that was a
very insecure stage in my life i talked
to you i said
i was before i wanted lamborghinis right
and it's funny because in that stage
when you're you're most insecure and
you're most searching for answers what i
tend to see especially on instagram
these days
is that is the stage where people arrive
at the conclusion
that they need a romantic partner to
complete them right yeah
and it's in fact what you've described
is no [ __ ] like that's the stage
where you need to do the self-work
yeah and then people form these like oh
well i had a huge gap
so i filled it with a romantic solution
yeah and
you complete me as one of the most
dangerous statements ever right
because you don't yeah
and eventually we're both going to
realize that i don't completely when you
don't complete me you've got to be
complete
to meet someone who's complete to begin
something new together and it's that um
the idea of you know your life their
life and the shared life
right and being willing to recognize
that they have to have a life
separate from yours and as you do
for you to build something together
that's separate and different
and i'm excited about that because i
feel as though my universe
looks the way that i've always wanted it
to i love the friends that i have you
know they're like family to me
i love the home that i have i love the
relationships that i have with my
my mother's like my mate now it's really
lovely and all of that has been work
that i've had to do on my own
so now i can come to the table as a
healthy grown-up
and make healthy conversation and have
healthy decision-making you know
damn society wants you to rush it though
doesn't it it really does
you know it really does but i mean our
parents generation all got married a lot
younger than we didn't
look at the divorce rates yeah i think
being happy with who you are
first is imperative to being able to
recognize someone who is happy within
themselves
your work you're doing so much at the
moment this is kind of where i wanted to
to end this is you're doing so much
across you know
your books you know your podcast i think
you've taken a little bit of a break
at the moment yeah yeah i'm gonna get
back to that but that's another
conversation your documentaries your
business
what are you most excited about what
does the future look like what is the
big
professional i mean if there is one
what's the big professional
i don't mean milestones i mean the big
professional
feeling you know what i mean the big
professional feeling is being creatively
fulfilled
in broad terms in more specific terms
it's
my business we haven't
actively launched yet but we are working
and operating and that is five seven so
i have a company called five seven
uh which is a people product and content
business
which has a cause arm we have past the
mic which is a platform that we created
for young creatives
which is growing and doing really
beautiful things in terms of empowering
diverse voices
right the way through to content we make
everything from feature films like
pirates or
you know make me famous um uh right the
way through to
uh product like blue skies so everything
that we do
at five seven has the fingerprints
of my outlook on the world
and this idea of understanding the power
of platform like
there are so many people that get to a
point of notoriety
and start selling slim tea
and there is no judgment on anybody that
does that but i
i judge you reggie doesn't but i do i
judge you
i always go back to that mom in the
street who stopped me and said
you're a role model for my kid and me
hating it and then finally coming around
to realizing i have no choice in the
mail
if you have an opportunity to make
movies to sell products
to make tv shows to create a cause-led
initiative
why not make it good why not make it
speak to what you care about why not
make it something that
can actively inspire other people to be
better than you are
and do more than you've ever done so for
me empowering others is a huge part of
my drive
right now and um working with young
talented people
inspires me to be better and as a result
i feel incredibly fulfilled you know i
don't see myself as a mentor but i've
technically
mentored three or four people and
they're like my little brothers and
sisters now that's how i see them
they're my friends who come around for
dinner or football or whatever and
you know guys and girls will call me and
ask for advice on their relationship or
on
a decision that they have to make
professionally and i love that i have
that relationship with people because i
never had it growing up
i had these bits of dad but i never had
the big brother
you know there was always a distance
between me and the person that was
helping guide me um shortening that
distance
for me in the lives of others
is what success feels like so the big
thing is being
creatively fulfilled
financially free and ultimately
understanding what it feels to love and
be loved
really and that's a journey that's what
we hope for
in your own view what is what is your
potential
um unlimited okay and i don't say that
because i think i'm lebron james
because i definitely can't dunk like
lebron yeah but i do
think that i don't think i know
anything that i've wanted to do like
really wanted to do
and i've really worked for i've achieved
i don't know
uh and because that has happened
it can happen in any way shape or form
my mother believes that she's quite a
spiritual woman as most west african
women are
i'm sure i'm sure you've got your
stories but she believes that
everybody's born with a gift right
my mother believed that my gift is to
see and to communicate
and she always said that to me since i
was a kid you know you can see and you
can communicate
um and the communication thing is sort
of panned out
it's you know essentially how i pay my
bills
sharing ideas and the the c part of it
is quite ambiguous in a lot of ways
because
what i've come to understand that to me
is that you know as a kid i used to
dream quite vivid things and they would
all come to pass
to you know learning about self and
doing some reading going some seminars
watching some stuff
you understand things about
manifestation all the rest of it and
that dream thing has sort of
changed into manifestation in a lot of
ways and when things start to happen
that you had in your head
it teaches you you can do anything yeah
and that's how i feel right now i feel
like i can do anything i had an idea
at a funeral of all places two years
later it's a movie
that is coming out in cinemas and
i genuinely think that anything that i
put my heart to and my mind to
i can i can make happen i can make it
real if that's your world view
and you you believe that and you've seen
it and you've got evidence for it in
your life that when you think about
something when you see it
you can then create it is it frustrating
when you speak to friends close friends
other people who express their dreams
to you yeah that they don't have that
too
no it's not reminds me right no but you
can't you can't be like that
and i'm i'm very i'm very specific about
words some
sometimes i try to be anywhere i hate
saying the word can't yeah i feel really
strongly about this
you can't allow yourself to think that
way because who they are is based on
their journey
yeah and they may beat that and get
beyond that
but you can't be mad at someone for
where they are on their own trajectory
yeah it's so it's like when i because i
have the same world view where
i've built those case personal case
studies in my life that i could go from
being in most sides stealing chicago
town pizzas to believe
to believing and chasing that dream
failing along the way messing up failure
whatever
but being able to create the the life
that i that i was aiming for
and so when i see friends who express
their dreams to me
and i deeply believe that whatever like
we're not talking about going to mars
right
we're talking about i want to be a
whatever or i want to try i know they
can do it
every part of me knows it's possible
because i've seen behind the curtain
and and they have what it takes and to
be fair when i started i had
like my math to ship my english [ __ ] my
parents weren't speaking to me we don't
come from a family that had any money
so i i know that the belief the
self-belief alone
the foundation of being born in such a
privileged country
is is more than they need to go after
that and i just have this [ __ ] thing
in me where i'm like
you know i'm like you can and it it you
know i
get i i definitely i i get you and i
hear you because i've definitely felt
that before
especially when it comes to young people
that want you to help them
or that want you to mentor them and you
take a chance on someone
and you give them all the information
you give them the blueprint you give
them all the tools
and they still don't listen or they
agree
and they do the total opposite mate it's
like practice for parenting isn't it
people that you love or invested in
aren't necessarily always going to do
what you think they should do
and you can't be mad at them for it
because it's their journey and
that is something that i'm incredibly
thankful for that the people that i've
had around me have allowed me
to not listen and make mistakes or go in
another direction like i had a huge huge
desire to be a musician
for a long time and i was making music
and i was offered a publishing deal and
i was
collaborating with everyone from i mean
i won't even say the names but you know
i made an album and
i had a deal on the table and i
i was adamant that this was what i was
going to do i was going to be the first
person that could host top of the pops
and perform on it like that was
that was my thing right and when my god
rested soul music lower at the time
richard and she sat me down and said
okay you see that top of the pops that
you're hosting you see that radio one
show that you've got you're gonna have
to leave all of that bro
to do this because you're gonna tour
you're gonna be in studio we're gonna
send you here there and there
the label will want you to record and
blah blah and i was like i don't wanna
give all that up
and it was like all right so are we
going to sign this thing or not
and i walked away from what would have
been another career
because ultimately it wasn't what i was
supposed to do and i wasn't willing to
give up the thing that i loved but i
needed to spend
three or four years of wasting the time
of people that were producers and and
and
singer-songwriters who come and
collaborate with me and people gave
studios were giving me free time record
labels were offering me contracts they
were rewriting them
all of this investment into me
for me to say now i'm just gonna go back
and do what i was doing before i met all
of you lot
sorry you know
i've done it i can't be mad at someone
else who's
doing a similar thing because there is
that point in your life where you have
to figure
out through mistakes or through trial
and error
what you're ultimately supposed to do
amen
i'm glad you agree no i do because i
would love you to challenge no i love
but i
that's why i do it because i know listen
i know that i'm like so so many of my
approaches in so many areas of my life
are so imperfect
but i love getting the perspective from
someone else because everything you've
said i
completely agree with and of course
you're of course you're right
but i still contend with that feeling
because there's this there's this like
bias in me that i've had it's it's
weakened over time but
really wants people to um feel what i
feel in my life
and uh and that is an awful bias because
it's projecting my own values and world
view
and what i think happiness for everyone
looks like onto them
um so i i yeah you're not the only one
you know i a million percent have done
that myself yeah and
even in relationships right absolutely
so absolutely if you do this you're
going to be like this
which means you're going to be just like
me and you're going to be great the most
frustrating one is whenever you say to
someone you say
what do you want and they go this and
you go okay here's how you get it and
they go oh [ __ ]
you know and you're like well you said
you wanted that this isn't that isn't
even my world view you said you want to
be a costa rican
belly dancer here is the cause and
they're like wow
well the truth is uncomfortable right
yeah and it's usually
[Music]
it's usually harder than people want it
to be and that
unfortunately in this conversation is
both the case for someone like yourself
who sat on one side of the table saying
this is what you need to do
and on the other side of the table the
person saying well i don't want to do
all of that
and what you both leave with is truth
and that is that you can't control
someone else and that is that
you've really got to do the things that
you aren't willing to do to get what you
want you know
amen listen reggie uh you know the work
you've done with your documentaries i
just think is tremendous and i think
i remember once upon a time listening to
i think it was neil degrasse tyson say
that the most
important work we can do or the most
important people in our society aren't
the
people we elect into power it's the
electorate that elect them
and so therefore the most important
powerful work one can do
is educating the electorate and what
that really means for me is like the way
that people think about whether it's
sexuality or regimes in other countries
whatever it might be
is the way they think dictates who they
then elect into power which then
impacts our laws in the society we live
in and that's the work you're doing and
i find that to be the most admirable
important work of it all so
thank you for doing that work thank you
for being a role model i mean i've
watched you
as a young kid growing up in plymouth
you know for
for many a decade and you know you've
been one of the faces that i even i
could relate to on tv because you look
like me
um and so i want to thank you for that
as well but also thank you for your time
today because i think the conversation
we've had has been very honest diverse
you've you know you've shared things
that you didn't have to share and um
i know that comes from a very selfless
desire to impart value on people that um
might need it in various areas of their
life so thank you
that's incredibly kind thank you for
having me thank you pleasure thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you